España ofrece nacionalidad para los
opositores políticos nicaragüenses que
fueron liberados por el gobierno de
Daniel Ortega este jueves el gobierno se
felicita ante la decisión de liberar a
222 presos de las cárceles en Nicaragua
también nos ofrecemos a que España acoja
a cualquier otro preso que se encuentre
todavía en estos momentos en la misma
situación que estos que acaban de ser
liberados y les anunció que el gobierno
ofrece la nacionalidad española a estos
222 presos liberados ante las noticias
de que se ha iniciado el trámite para
declararles apátridas uno de los que
recobró la libertad fue el ex
precandidato presidencial Juan Sebastián
Chamorro quien desde Washington celebró
la decisión del gobierno español Este es
un ofrecimiento generoso que nos llena
de Esperanza Es una muy buena noticia en
lo particular Pues de esto no lo estamos
aprendiendo estamos formándonos
momentos de esa de esa política Pero
estoy seguro de que más de es mucho de
los 222 este preso podrían este ya estar
tomando decisiones al respecto hay un
par de presos políticos que yo
personalmente conozco es que tienen
familiares en España estoy seguro de que
es un es una una política de acción
humanitaria sumamente importante con
Chamorro eran siete los aspirantes a la
presidencia que fueron encarcelados
cuando se enfrentaban a Ortega en las
controvertidas elecciones de 2021 que la
comunidad internacional ha catalogado
como una farsa Estados Unidos dijo que
esta decisión era un paso constructivo
es que a la mejora de los derechos
humanos desde 2018 centenares de
personas fueron enviados a prisión en
unas duras protestas antigubernamentales
que fueron reprimidas por las
autoridades de forma violenta más de 325
personas murieron según la cidh y miles
han huido al exi